- The thickness of that meat
cannot be taken lightly.
That is just, it's almost
breathtakingly beautiful.
I didn't actually need
teeth to bite through that.
I could've used pure gums.
(upbeat music)
Good morning, everyone, it's Mark Wiens
with migrationology.com in New York City.
We are out this morning,
it's about 7:30 a.m.
and we are gonna start this
morning with a monumental
place to eat.
We're walking over to the subway station,
gonna head south to Lower Manhattan.
(upbeat music)
(speaks foreign language)
We ended up buying the
Metro Card which is a card
for the subway and then
you put credit on it.
We are trying to figure
out the station now,
walking down to the train.
We got off the metro at
2nd Ave and the restaurant
should just be a short walk from here.
I'm getting excited.
The legendary, the historic,
the home of the ultimate
pastrami sandwich in New York
City, Katz's Delicatessen.
Though I have visited New
York City a couple of times,
this is gonna be my first
time to ever eat here.
Hello.
- Here you go.
- Thank you.
- Enjoy.
- [Mark] We gotta keep this,
we gotta keep this, I think.
What's the difference
between the Reuben pastrami
and the pastrami sandwich.
- [Man] It's just the
texture of the sandwich.
We can make the Reuben with the pastrami,
and it comes with Russian
dressing, sauerkraut
and Swiss cheese.
- It's just after 8 a.m.
right as they have opened
this morning, this is
the perfect time to come
because when you come
here later in the day,
it's normally just absolutely packed out
and you have to wait in line.
Right at the entrance,
they give you tickets.
Then after that, I'm trying
to figure out the system,
but then you walk to one
of the bar counters here
and you place in your order.
They have the menus up at
the top and so I have just
placed in my order.
- This is Eli.
- And this is Eli.
- His server.
- My server.
- Gonna make him very happy.
- [Mark] Oh yeah.
- Everything's gonna be fantastic.
- Thank you, man.
- No problem.
- Oh yeah.
- This is the corned beef.
- [Mark] Corned beef, okay.
- [Eli] For my friend, what's your name?
- Mark.
This for you and your wife, Mark.
- Oh man, thank you.
Eli has just sliced me a fresh
piece of the corned beef.
Oh yeah.
It's tender, you can taste the saltiness
and the light spice.
So what time does it start
to get really busy here?
- About 10:30, 11 o'clock.
Eat all of this, don't embarrass me.
- [Mark] Okay.
- Give some to your wife.
(mumbles) table.
(speaks foreign language)
- [Mark] This is the pastrami?
- Yeah, man.
You guys know what you want?
(laughing)
- Thank you.
- You and your wife.
- [Mark] Awesome.
- [Eli] Wait until you taste that.
You're gonna jump for joy.
- It's time for my taste
of the pastrami now.
You can see that ratio,
that outer crust edge,
that pink interior with the fat.
- [Eli] Fat, good stuff.
- That just melts in your mouth.
Oh, Reuben.
That's insane.
- You two slugs, get up here.
Gonna be a great day.
- My joy and excitement right now is
at an unparalleled level.
I got my tray of food and
the main thing that I wanted,
that I have to eat here,
that you have to eat here
when you come to this
restaurant is the pastrami.
You can either order just
the pastrami sandwich
or you can order the
Reuben which is a sandwich
that includes pastrami.
I went with the Reuben
and it also includes
some Russian sauce, plus
sauerkraut and I think
there's some cheese on there as well.
And then I also, I could not resist trying
the corned beef so I had
to a half of corned beef,
all on rye plus a side of
pickles plus a side of coleslaw.
These are possibly the most beautifully
exploding meat sandwiches.
This is the Reuben with pastrami.
The ratio of meat to
bread is just an absolute
sensational thing and
there's sauerkraut on here
and then that sauce and yeah,
and Eli really hooked it up
with the samples already
so I've already tasted
the pastrami and it is
absolutely ridiculous.
Look at this thing just steaming away.
The thickness of that meat
cannot be taken lightly.
That is just, it's almost
breathtakingly beautiful.
I am a big fan of taking big bites,
but this is the next level of big bites.
That'll just make you,
that is an eye closer.
I didn't actually need
teeth to bite through that.
I could've used pure gums.
It's so tender, it's perfectly salted.
You can taste that peppery
crust on the outside
and then with the Russian
mustard I think is a little bit
sweet plus the cheese
and the sour crispness
of that sauerkraut.
What I love is that the juices and the fat
of the pastrami have
soaked into the bread.
I probably have something
on my chin and lips.
But when you hold the
bread on your fingers,
it's still dry on the
outside, but that fat
and that juice has made
like half of the bread
gooey and just full of juices.
I might add some more mustard.
There's no way I'm gonna lift the lid
on this sandwich, so I'm
just gonna put it on top.
Oh yes, just look at the amount of cheese
that's hanging out of it as well.
The mustard is awesome, that
brings it to another level
of flavor, it's a little
bit sour and you can taste
that turmericy flavor to it.
Halfway through my first half of sandwich,
I think this would be an
appropriate time to take
a bite of the pickle.
There's two different
types of pickles here.
This one is more of a
green looking cucumber
and this one looks like
it's been brined for longer
and I think that is the tomatillo.
Maybe a green tomato pickle.
I love pickles too.
It's salty, it's not sweet at all.
This is just a kosher pickle.
This one definitely has
more sour taste to it.
It's been pickled for longer.
I'm gonna go ahead and move
over to the corned beef.
This one is just the corned
beef, it's a half a sandwich.
You just have to admire how
many layers of corned beef
are in here, two, four, six, eight,
at least 10 layers of meat
are filled into this sandwich.
The corned beef is awesome too.
It's not as tender as the pastrami.
Because it's corned beef, it
has that saltier flavor to it.
Very good as well, but I
think I gotta give it up
for that pastrami, it
just needs some mustard,
some more mustard.
The meat goes so well
together with that mustard.
We also got a side of coleslaw.
Let me taste the coleslaw.
A little bit sweet and tangy
and very creamy and milky,
and then the cabbage has a
very crisp texture to it.
I gotta try this as well.
As soon as you bite that, you have to.
It just explodes with juice
so you have to make sure
you get all that juice.
Has a wonderful garlicy taste to it
and then that's amazing.
It's tart, it's nice and sour, it's salty,
it's garlicy and it's so juicy.
The tenderness of that
pastrami cannot be exaggerated.
You could use every
tender adjective possible
to describe that and you would
not be able to exaggerate
how tender and how flavorful
and just how beautiful
that pastrami meat was.
That was insanely delicious.
The corned beef was good but
the pastrami just blew it away.
That was definitely a lot of
meat to eat in the morning
but I'm really glad that
Ying and I came here
as soon as they opened
early in the morning
because it was the perfect time to come.
No waiting in line and now we get to burn
all of that beautiful meat
for the rest of the day
walking around.
We're just gonna kinda walk around.
I think we're in the Lower
East Side area of Manhattan
right now, we're gonna walk
on over towards Chinatown.
Maybe take a look at Brooklyn Bridge
and just kind of wander today.
(upbeat music)
We made it successfully to Chinatown.
I love Chinatown, so much action happening
and so many good restaurants
that we have passed
but we're gonna keep
on walking all the way
to the bridge, gonna go take a look
at the Brooklyn Bridge
and then maybe come back
to Chinatown for lunch.
(upbeat music)
Ying saw the cherries
and she could not resist.
We just ordered a pound of cherries.
That should be (mumbles).
It's 59 cents per pound.
This is one dollar.
(speaks foreign language)
Is it one dollar?
- Thank you.
Yes, nice to meet you.
(chattering)
Thank you.
We made it to the East River,
have the Manhattan
Bridge over to this side.
Brooklyn across the river and then
the famous Brooklyn bridge.
We are walking through Chinatown again.
Chinatown is awesome in New York City.
It is really as close
to China as you can get
without being in China.
It's amazing, you can get
so many food ingredients,
so much of everything you
could possibly imagine.
(speaks foreign language)
Can we have that spicy
big tray of chicken?
- [Waitress] With noodles?
- With noodles, yeah.
Since we were walking around Chinatown,
I had to come to this restaurant,
it's called Spicy Village.
Thank you very much to Monty
for this recommendation.
This is an awesome little place.
You walk in here, it's
just a small restaurant
with maybe a half a dozen tables in here.
They do have a full menu on a paper
but then they have their
main specialty dishes listed
and pictured on the wall.
The main dish that I had to try here is
the Big Tray Chicken, I was
just looking up this restaurant
and someone wrote about it
from The New York Times.
He said he went into the
kitchen and saw how they make it
and they add a unique mixture
of different ingredients
into the chicken including
oil and Budweiser
and then fry the chicken and then drain it
and then fry it again and
then it goes into a spicy
chili filled broth with Szechuan peppers.
You can smell the cumin in
here and I got it with noodles.
All of the chicken is down here below
and the big pile of noodles,
I think there's even
some potatoes in here.
Oh look at this, this is just pretty.
Let me take my bowl.
Maybe I should just taste
some of that broth first.
Let me taste some of the soup.
That is insane.
You can really taste the
Szechuan pepper in there.
You can taste the cumin
nice and strong as well.
It's salty, that is outstanding.
Mix in noodles with the
(speaks foreign language),
mix in noodles with the soup.
You can actually see
also, you can just see
how much cumin is in there.
There's so much cumin and so
many Szechuan peppers in here.
There's a fantastic cumin flavor to it.
It'll be easier to eat
from my single bowl.
Some chicken.
Okay chicken time.
You can tell that the
chicken has been fried
because it has this skin around it
like a fried skin around it.
But then the inside is
so tender, it's juicy,
it's like filled with that broth.
That is insanely good.
And then some of the noodles.
You can see all of the
Szechuan peppers in there,
the cumin seeds.
Wow, you can immediately tell
those are handmade noodles.
They are chewy but yet
they are fresh tasting
and I love how they're a thick
cut so they're a little bit
thick but they're gooey
but just perfectly chewy.
And then again the noodles
are just wrapped up,
soaked up with that
incredibly flavorful broth.
The Szechuan pepper, the chili
and especially that cumin,
that cumin is what's
really blowing me away.
Finished eating that big tray
chicken, that is sensational.
That was so incredibly good.
What really just took it to the next level
was that amount of cumin as
well as that Szechuan pepper.
My mouth is still a little bit numb.
I love Szechuan peppers,
it's one of my favorite
ingredients in the entire world.
They used it marvelously
in this combination.
That was truly a masterpiece
of a dish within a tray.
So good, the cumin is just
going up my nose right now.
It was so good.
We have decided to head back to the subway
and we are gonna go back to Midtown,
maybe do a little bit of shopping.
I wanna go to Trader
Joe's and buy some walnuts
and some other snacks.
Then maybe we'll go back to the hotel
for a little while and then after that
maybe walk around Times Square.
(upbeat music)
This is Avenue, I was
thinking it's down that way.
We got off the subway at 23rd Street
and here is Trader Joe's.
We're gonna go in here for a little while
and do some shopping.
(speaks foreign language)
We were only gonna go into Trader Joe's
and buy a couple of things but ended up
with a whole sack of things.
Ying and I were both excited.
We bought raspberries and
almonds and almond milk
and bananas and walnuts.
Yeah, I'm a big fan of Trader
Joe's when I am visiting
the United States.
We went back to the hotel
and stayed for about an hour
and now we are walking
down 7th Avenue on our way
to Times Square.
(electronic music)
This is Times Square.
We made it right into the center
of New York's Times Square.
This is a huge, just absolutely
packed with people square
and I just read that it's
one of the world's busiest
pedestrian walkways in the entire world
with over 400,000 people
on average per day
who walk through Times Square
but it's just an insanity
of lights and billboards.
- I see your videos all the time.
- Thank you, what's your name?
- Hello.
- Andrea.
- Nice to meet you.
Where are you from?
- Venezuela.
- Hello!
- And there's just an insanity of lights
and flashing billboards and advertisements
and everything going on.
Everything you could
possibly want to ever buy
there's advertising for it
somewhere within Times Square.
(electronic music)
Not too far away from
Times Square is a place
I have been waiting to eat for a long time
and we have just arrived
at the corner of 6th Avenue
and 53rd Street.
Halal Guys.
They are one of the most
well known street food trucks
or street food establishments
in all of New York.
Famous for serving Halal
food and since we happened
to be in this area, I
thought this would make
a perfect dinner.
I know exactly what I'm gonna order.
I'm gonna go for the chicken rice plate,
extra white sauce and extra hot sauce.
I can actually smell, actually
this entire plaza area
which is just surrounded
by gigantic buildings
is filled with the aroma of the chicken.
The Halal Guys were
established back in 1990
and they were a pioneer in the street food
in New York City as well as Halal food.
You can see how they are
preparing food for the masses
right now, they're cooking chicken,
just heaps of chicken and that aroma
is enough to make your
mouth water immediately.
- Chicken and beef.
(mumbles)
- Yes?
- Chicken and rice, one plate.
(mumbles)
But I don't wanna lean back too far
because this is a fountain
and there are some drips
coming down and there's water
below where I'm sitting.
So don't lean back too far.
The unveiling of The Halal
Guys' chicken over rice.
Oh yes, you can smell
that, it smells incredible.
What else came in here?
This is the white sauce,
the famous white sauce
that includes soy beans
and egg yolk and vinegar
and water, salt, lots of good stuff.
And then extra hot sauce, all right.
That's actually, that's pretty heavy.
That's a good sized portion.
Oh yeah, here it is.
Chicken over rice, the rice
is very orange in color
on the bottom.
There's some iceberg lettuce
and then pieces of bread.
Okay the security just came over
and said we can't sit on a fountain.
So I gotta take my Halal Guys elsewhere.
(speaks foreign language)
We'll try the flower planter this time
instead of the fountain.
Let's do this one more time.
Correct procedure is to
take the packets of sauce
and just drench this entire
plate with all of that sauce.
But I'm gonna go ahead
and just taste a piece
of the chicken before
drenching it in sauce
with some of that rice.
It's not overly spicy or spiceous.
It's kind of just like fried chicken
like griddle fried chicken
but very tender chicken
and over fluffy, orange rice.
I think a lot of the
flavor is in that sauce.
Oh yeah.
And from what everybody says,
you can not have enough white sauce.
They had hot sauce.
I'll go with just one packet
of the white sauce for now
and then the red sauce.
The hot sauce.
Then stir this all up with the chicken.
Oh that beautiful swirl.
All right, I think that is perfect.
I am not waiting any longer.
It is all about the
combinations of those sauces.
Because the chicken and the rice,
tasting it on its own,
it really is quite plain.
But when you add that
sauce, that just adds
the world of difference.
That is the secret of
The Halal Guys for sure.
It kind of tastes yogurty.
But then reading the
ingredients, it says soy bean
and then also egg yolk and
vinegar, and water and salt.
It has a little bit of a
sour yogurty taste to it.
It's creamy and that
hot sauce is fantastic.
It is definitely a little bit spicy.
Some good heat to it and
just fantastic flavor.
Wow, that is like
surprisingly awesomely good
once you mix both of the sauces in.
Yeah this hot sauce is incredibly good.
I wanna get some of the chicken
with only the hot sauce.
Let me see what's all in this hot sauce.
There is water, spices,
vinegar, salt, lemon,
yeah those are mostly the ingredients.
Oh yeah.
That hot sauce is amazing.
It does have a kick to
it, it is nice and spicy
and then it has a really
sharp lemony kind of acidic
slightly bitter taste to it.
That is a wonderful hot sauce.
That was a lot of hot sauce in that bite.
That was amazing.
And then I think I will just add on.
This hot sauce is remarkably
spicy, it's fantastic.
I think I'm getting the hang of this.
You want every piece of
chicken and every morsel
of rice, every grain of
rice to just be coated
in hot sauce and white sauce.
Don't let anything not get sauce on it.
What I love so much about New York City
is the diversity which
leads to just the full world
of possibilities when it comes to food.
So for breakfast we had
that insanely good pastrami,
for lunch we had that
unbelievably good hot pot
of chicken and noodles
and Szechuan pepper.
Then for dinner, that New
York Middle Eastern inspired
chicken over rice from The Halal Guys.
That was an awesome day of eating.
Thank you all very much
for watching this video.
Please remember to give it a
thumbs up if you enjoyed it
and also make sure you
subscribe for lots more food
and travel videos.
Good night from New York City.
Thank you again for watching.
Oh hello Ying.
Welcome to Times Square.
- Times for shopping.
Say something.
- Is there a tear?
Is there a tear in my eye?
- Yeah.
- The hot sauce was that good.